yeah yeah yeah Wow
it's on its trailer commentaries I put
the clue for next one up at the top I
like them yeah this is the show we
talked about the honest trailer for
Mission Impossible fall out what we're
really thinking what didn't make it onto
the screen and whatever other
digressions we get into Joestar Demerol
can't fight the friction can't fight the
friction yeah where does that sit with
you that or the limp Biskit cover of
Mission Impossible oh fave I think I
think just cuz it's the newest like this
that's the best trailer of the year that
first movies the best trailer still oh
yeah
Joe you a biscuit man man you know I got
to go like Red Lobster at those cheddar
biscuits oh yeah man that song is the
whole thing which one the biscuit
mission impossible sound yeah I don't
think um it was in the movie it wasn't
was it
neither one credit don't remember if
there's an instrumental version that I
think perhaps was there should be a
whole album of people of new metal bands
cover they did their own Mission
Possible style of video yeah yeah on the
cliff where it's like hello mr. Durst
monster energy drink has been replaced
with an explosive we need you to chug so
yeah we probably talked about the movie
at some point yeah a fine film and a
fine franchise this is super fun yeah
not my favorite Mission Impossible but
I'm the weirdo that likes the first one
the best oh I like the like more of the
whodunit kind of European intrigue but
now it's become like fast and furious on
legs but it's amazing like it's
incredible I'm not complaining I am
complaining this is probably the best
action franchise we have running I would
agree with that
I'm the weirder weirder who likes three
the best but this was actually right
right up there like three five and
Forza I'm not as big on for as a lot of
people be like three five and six are
the three that I'm like right here and
then I like to I like the first one BAM
and then I like four and then two for me
this like way down here what's the one
where they guy jump into the underwater
thing that's the last one six five five
well it's interesting that this scene
from one I don't know if that's my
favorite Mission Impossible movie okay
that's my favorite several minutes and
um she was super dunk tank yeah yeah
it's really leaning on your ability to
remember what happened in the past
Mission Impossible movie it has always
been an Achilles heel for myself I know
personally yeah which one was that right
as we've just proved yeah and it's not
too long ago that like did you watch
them all for cram it or did you do cram
it I did the vo for Yamit I think I know
I'm I'm the least expert on our
programming it literally just like goes
right out my I might out of my mind the
second that it's done but I believe yes
I did the V over cram it which helped
immensely in remembering on a personal
level what happened and I rewatched the
last one also in its entirety that way I
can remember Solomon Lane and never yeah
that would really helped and cuz they're
not I mean well the plots kind of fall
apart like most movies do if you really
dig at it because there's like quintuple
crosses going on in this one and like
the apostles are so shadowy and where
does Henry Cavill have the time like I
barely have time to like do my laundry
and work here and he's like risen
through the entire ranks of the CIA well
also well also building a secret shadow
network writing manifestos yeah - that
out hiring fake him themselves yeah
hiring fake him selves that's a lot like
if he's gonna hire a fake himself to
take out why hire like the best badass
martial artists in the universe
who's gonna like take on you better hope
Tom Cruise can hold his own when they
supposed to kill that guy yes they were
posted okay so he's hiring a guy to tend
to be the guy tend to be the guy so that
he'll earn the trust by killing the guy
that's right but he hired like a badass
like he could easily have killed well I
guess not both of them but definitely
Tom Cruise and then where would they be
I mean they should have hired a guy
who's like basically tying his own
shoelaces together who's like like
that's the guy he should have hired that
isn't good if it was like a mr. bean
situation yeah and Tom Cruise and Henry
Cavill kept hurting themselves trying to
[Laughter]
be slightly less beany yeah what else
happened in this film Tom Cruise
obviously is a man on a mission to hang
from the highest heights ever higher
yeah and out of a plane last time and he
jumped out of a higher plane yeah and he
did and then he hung out of a helicopter
he did that jump like a ton of times too
I'm sure
the halo jump yet yeah shot perfectly
because you have to like rack focus on
his face while the the cameraman doesn't
get enough props cuz he's jumping out of
play or the camera can't get Jesus yeah
but you know if that's the last thing
you ever see I think you had a good life
well you know if something's gonna go
wrong like if I were gonna do multiple
halo jumps with any movie star it would
be Tom Cruise because you know he'd
rescue you because that's what he does
like Tom Cruise is like it's like an
actual superhero yeah sources say yeah
sources say uh well I'm sure we have
more to say as we want yeah the Mission
Impossible Fall Out Boy's trailer the
following trailer is going to ask for
spoilers
I don't care but they give away the
movies old pots I don't understand why
people watch these if they haven't seen
the movie they do it it's uh I if people
get annoyed I never understood it
if people get annoyed that we put the
spoiler tag on it I will take the blame
for that because it's me
because we've been yelled at so much for
some oily movies yeah I agree if you're
watching the honest trailer you probably
should have first of all just from a
humor standpoint seeing the movie is
kind of an employer's help it helps it
certainly helps but I we've been yelled
at too many times for spoiling movie
people watch this before the honest
trailer which is also urines weird weird
you guys we don't understand that's I
don't understand you yeah we're happy
you're here don't leave with the world
hangs in the balance
Tom Cruise will hang and balance in the
franchise that keeps pushing him to top
the last one until he dies making one of
these and we examine our own role in
this deadly game of stunts you're good
learn how to fly a helicopter possible
mission force on their most dangerous
mission yet getting their hands on some
balls and has his best friend and
ex-wife work together to stop those
balls from exposed this is what I think
is fun about these they treat this so
seriously yes thank you nuclear warheads
that it's funny when you just like it
they really are just chasing around a
bunch of balls yeah yeah they got to get
the balls they got to get the ball out
of the machine they have to yeah I do
appreciate the balls because it was more
tangible than the last six of them would
have been like the NOC list the rabbit's
foot and it's a never what you think it
is yeah the Pantera's album they always
have these like stupid code names yeah
no this is just three balls yeah nuclear
balls really radioactive balls I can
wrap my head around that yeah that's
easy they weren't like
they didn't like at one point like crack
opened the ball and inside is a hard
drive that leads to like an underground
facility where the real bombers there
were never any balls there it's all it's
like no there's three nuclear balls yeah
yep
yeah yeah they're gonna explode you can
reach out you can touch them they're
real yeah that's what I only drew
matically all from something that's what
always drove me crazy a lot of times
it's like the ADA it never went from A
to B it was always like a to z to our
database it'll give you access to the
database to decode the cipher you spent
30 minutes pulling off a heist to steal
something that it turns out never really
needed anyway so you could have actually
skipped the 30 minutes of the heist and
just gone but you know the friends we've
made along the way yeah so I like the
fact this is a very they've got nuclear
balls and we've got to get those nuclear
balls back yeah it's these movies are
really streamlined er this one was
really streamlined despite all the the
twists and turns and it's it's weird
that like how did the last one end
because this one opens with Tom Cruise
just on a cot just like lying back like
just like waiting for the next movie
just fully dressed
he's just so ready to go it's like your
mission with them they tricked the guy
into the glass cage of emotion
underneath the subway and gassed them
and they gave them over to the agents
Alec Baldwin took over the IMF because
yeah I'm gonna close it down again again
again they're like Thank You mr.
secretary
yeah or whatever and got at the exactly
so and then you have anyone stand back
right back to that car yeah yeah he's a
simple man yes he's like a dog chasing
the ball no let's keep going
but notice I caught I don't have enough
hands tom buddy
we know you still got it you have to ram
it down our throats with the metaphors
[Music]
every mi yet so of course you were
thrilled when Solomon Lane returned no
you don't remember him well you do
remember the badass mi6 agent Ilsa no
that's his wife from mi3 that's just
some random cop and now that's Katie
Holmes okay
and you remember a single syndicate
right that's Hydra that Spectre fine
forget everything you never remembered
in the first place
because our heroes are up against the
apostles and they've got a plan to wipe
out a third of the global population
that's Thanos loot boobie I'm here to
watch Tom hang from stuff where six
missions in and I still call the Ving
Rhames character Bing range why'd you
have to make this way speaking of people
that look like people yeah Solomon Lane
I thought the first movie he didn't have
the beard that he was gonna be like
simon Pegg's brother like is he not he
bears from to me a striking resemblance
to Simon Pegg which threw legitimately
was first time I was watching five I was
like is that did they put Benji and a
mask right is that prosthetic Simon Pegg
in bad press that yeah like it's they do
like they have this thing where they
cast similar looking people in different
roles it's even harder like Billy Crudup
and Jonathan Rhys Meyers oh yeah I don't
know if they are in the same movie but I
I could easily get them can feet then
the other thing we discovered in this
film is that I sound like Solomon Lane
when I'm impersonating Jason stay yes
yes yes what you doing Jason Statham but
actually Solomon dead suddenly so first
any ADR he needs fresh bold seven I'm
your guy the problem with the you
remember this guy right you don't it's
because we just met him in the last
movie and now and the last one he's like
real clean-cut he's got glasses and now
in this he like looks like the lead
singer at the National and he's just
like got this huge shaggy beard and so I
was legitimate like when I saw that
initial awesome preview I was like who's
the guy in the
police truck that's turning on its side
with the one I was like I don't know who
that is yeah but he's a big deal I guess
I don't know yeah yeah big bushy beard
great big bushy beard and I think we're
gonna talk about Henry Capital in a
second but like I wouldn't mind if he
came back I might be crawled out of that
like with the hook in his head not a
cliff on an Allen copter which exploded
yet his master was set up in a way where
I believe if you just like crawled back
yeah then you go can't be bond and he's
literally called like hook head like I'm
fine with that
much more than Darth Maul he's the
character that I would believe coming
back to the robot like yes I add of
everyone well we're gonna talk about it
more in a second let's keep it let's get
20 the gang or if you saw the trailer
betraying the gang is the secret agent
August Walker a role that cements Henry
Cavill as composed of pins from seeds
he's a spy you could go undercover as
anyone from an NFL linebacker to Hagar
from final fight for a second like the
premise of this character is very stupid
but I love it yeah the sense that like
the IMF does things to secretly now the
CIA we like to go in guns blazing like
to sit in this eight-foot for holes like
the army okay or the Marines but they're
like we're the CIA we bring a hammer
chisel chisel group ever
[Laughter]
sorry it was cool to have the
juxtaposition but like don't make a CIA
undercover Johnny Utah was a better
undercover agent yes and he was posing
as a quarterback Johnny Utah was a
better undercover agent as himself than
Henry Cavill is as
John lark / August wow I guess Walker
which is like a anagram I think now
maybe you solve it with like he's he's
our last resort guy when like sneaking
around and blah blah blah like ain't
working anymore
oh yeah but they mentioned in the movies
that the whole reason that Ethan doesn't
trust him is that he's literally because
he's John Mark and he's covering his
tracks but like he literally kills
everybody that they go after I'm like so
you bring in that guy in instead of the
ones that are gonna jab him with a pen
or like drop something in his drink yeah
and then replace him with a full mask
replica no one will ever know is like no
let's also send the guy who's literally
killed every informant we've sent in the
track they need to get the information
now from his smashing heads together
yeah
the trailer thing was weird because
watching the trailer I remember being
like oh well there's like four or five
moves left yeah in this will they won't
they that we just don't reveal it and
it's like him as the bad guy yeah and
it's like oh nope he's just the bad guy
yeah yeah and we already knew that it
was so yeah they they did their ematic
reveal of him twice which was bizarre
because there's one where you the
audience knows because it's like he
gives the unmatched phone and it's not
much is made of it though but like from
then on you know he's evil well yeah
because it's like obvious he's like it's
Ethan Hunt and they're like well I know
that it's not because it's knives our
special boy so you're obviously the bad
guy but yeah the movie keeps playing for
45 minutes like he's not and then it's
like oh yeah yeah I know
romantic speech he starts monologuing
like gotcha like we got yet yeah we were
aware he knew the plan was to put Simon
Pegg in a Solomon Lane mask and yet when
Solomon Lane is sitting mutely in front
of him in a chair not speaking yeah he's
still gonna be like I'm gonna tell you
my whole plan hammered a Solomon Lane
doing them a solid when they're swapping
him out like staying completely silent
oh hi lovely August and lovingly
overhead he was just standing there
around the corner
it's shenanigans it's just completely
quiet while they swap but he's the great
villain he was a good villain
yeah good villain yep but he was good by
being like silent and mysterious yeah
that's not the most memorable thing from
film to film but you know I out of
everyone that I feel like they have set
up to be the ethan replacement because i
guess a few times Tom's been like maybe
I need to stop jumping off things soon
because it seemed like it was Rhys
Meyers yeah and then it was stupid
Renner and out of anybody I thought it
would it'd be interesting if it was
Cavill in the next one and Ving Rhames
is like man you can't just like go in
and just beat the [ __ ] out of everybody
he's like I do things differently but
that would have been fun they could have
a movie you know yeah now he's okay it's
just like him and and this Benji like
just mouths of gape is just murders
every single person at the party okay
okay keep going
complete with arms that require a reload
and I'm so down so powerful such a total
the DCE unit names that Mary know it's
gonna go down when he finally faces off
against his most brutal foe yet on the
record in the movie being the best
contract killer I think I'll take a run
yes Colin a girdle
in this scene just like and also right
before this he's like wow it's kind of
fun being out in the field for the first
time or he's like wow this is I see why
you guys like it out there
yeah so that's going from like I got a I
walked on to the college team - just
like rooting your way into the the first
team all-american yeah yeah also that I
know I'm sure that Baldwin was like I
gotta look like a man
yeah but like that record with Nick
let's turn it off but that fight she
should have been he like throws three
punches in Henry Cavill just picks him
up and throws him into the Sun like yeah
like he's go island like the guy doing
the heroic last day
yeah yeah well next time let's keep
golden Alec he wanted out of the
franchise just disappear like jeremy
renner did more Paula Patton or Danny
Newton or Jonathan Rhys Meyers or
Laurence Fishburne or Anthony Hopkins
what are these people go that way that's
because we talk about like they lean in
to stuff that you don't necessarily
remember but I think if you're going to
and this was supposed to be a bow unlike
the first five movies a writer which
McCrory said it was supposed to be like
go harder don't just be like that lady
is Max's daughter like go crazy like
haven't any Newton show it would be like
I'm an apostle and just whatever the
kitchen why all your stops kids teachers
yeah he had a huge busty and he like got
the necklace back yeah nope the last the
last scene should be Henry Cavill and he
like wakes up in a hospital for villains
and genre knows shows up with his burned
up face and he's like I'll teach you how
to deal it's fine well and then he takes
off the mask and it's John yeah I think
he just you just leave it were night
anyway I said yes Lena leaning in was
the problem we did but look right in the
nose leaning it more would not have
helped yes smooth criminal' lean right
[Laughter]
yeah just let these stand alone I think
let's keep on fakes of intrigue and
cardio as the last five of these things
and don't mind that they still lean on
the Maastricht guard or use the same
halo jump sequence as two other bad
robot productions or have a weirdly
similar ending to return citizen this is
I was what I did not catch this in the
theater Rosa you're watching this and I
was like he's outside he loses
consciousness on a rock it fades to
white he wakes up in a hospital bed
there's a someone looming over him in a
full face shot he's asking what's
happening they're talking to him and
then
friends walk in the door like this is a
little librarian in your head started
flipping through exactly the rolodex
isn't like this is Frodo waking up at
the end of Return of the King
it's kind of weird it's like my friends
there's actually a third ending where
he's about to go board a ship Baldwin is
like Bing reims is like the Eagles just
gets on his back yeah it's very weird
actually there's a helicopter it does
he's he's laying on the rock it's weird
it's all I'm saying is it's really weird
odd yeah anyway yeah Tamar you know
little movie DNA I'm still stuck on ving
rhames flapping his wings like an eagle
flying somebody I think you're gonna
enjoy one of the best action movies of
the year because the next one might be
his last season hunt
Benji man's buttons you know cuz he's
Manning the buttons let yours Scarlett
Johansson Scarlett Johansson
wow what a chameleon yeah tryin and
[ __ ] news of Justice never see the
nubra River Valley isn't ending rings
contract that he never has to stand up
was good oh man he's the van guy yeah
yeah their van in boss as we say deleted
scenes will roll right now look starring
two-faced guy fall Cool Runnings Tom
possible but Allah who threw van boss
during the rough one as tough they're
different funny hello my name is Simon
warm paws gentle Benji Jane bond Faust
and furious blows felled white widow why
isn't there a but oh right please do
white oh yeah cruisin for a bruisin that
you would not survive the house now
Mission Impossible 6ot
level seven balls out balls out fall out
boys
Skyfall wasn't that song in the movie
there was a cut where John tried to sing
it but it wasn't okay it's a tough one
to imagine dragons is hard to correct
yeah okay for those that are always like
woo to look in the writers room I'll
tell you this particular story in title
session was like an hour of us just
silently glaring at our laptop so we
occasionally say something that might
rhyme vague yeah that's the last Mission
Impossible trailer we did was for
everything up until like through five
and yeah it was just tropes you know so
we didn't have to deal with actors names
or character names which it turns out
nobody remembers anyways so yeah yeah
yeah oh well I guess that's pretty much
everything we had to say what would you
like to see as the the trailer sell you
on the movie stunts for Tom Cruise for
Mission Impossible 7
oh god for the next one he outruns the
Mars rover like on Mars like he's
actually goes to Mars he's really there
and in a spacesuit and just like running
against gravity okay that's the Sun I
will see I guess I want to see him
tunnel to the center of the earth
just just rip his way to the core and
then and then cannonball through it see
we give Daniel day-lewis so much credit
for like I lived in a cabin but like Tom
Cruise is like I did 700 halo jumps
yeah oh you act like Abraham Lincoln is
so hard I broke my ankle jumping from a
building why would they need to do they
need to start doing the Jackie Chan
credits for these movies where they just
show context
yeah bloopers let's say they need to
hire dale day-lewis to play Tom Cruise
and a biopic and then he'll just have to
fall shadow him and then he pulls off
his mask in his Henry Cavill so how
exactly yeah just imagine you're the
mass displacement yeah perfect
I think they go out on a high note you
did good they did good they're good all
right they did great that's cool they
just stopped three nuclear bombs from
going off two of them simultaneously
yeah to wipe out every character from
almost every different movie in the
franchise at once like he seems to have
found a new similar enough looking wife
potentially yeah yeah because in the
last movie was cool that they were just
like I don't know we're spy buds yeah
and then this movie was like finally
they can love each other
spy buds I also would have been down if
the the nuclear bomb thing hadn't been a
fake out I'm a lot of fake outs in this
movie kinda down with the franchise
direction being like we keep the world
stable now that like three bombs went
off that would have been interesting
yeah and it is the title is kind of a
head-fake because like oh wow you're
gonna have to deal with the fallout from
all of the things that went wrong that
they screwed up in but it was all the
tree yeah that's right there was the
other the beginning fake out or he's
getting married yes that's a fake out
then like Ethan would have to like do
something morally compromising for the
greater good fake out where he's like
shooting cops and stuff like that was oh
yeah that was also faked out and then
the bombs going off Vica pika more like
mission impossible too late all right
well you guys already got your clue but
we hope you'll come back next week for
more hilarity right here context right
[Music]
you